[Music]
all right let's go out to onario Canada
and talk to Jess's girl what's up
Jesse hey Dr John how you doing we're
doing all right man how about you I'm
doing okay very good man what's
happening is it
cold you know what it snowed a little
bit last night for the first time we had
a we had a white Christmas actually ah
very good man congratulations was quite
warm oh thanks yeah it was good what's
up all right well I've been uh really
struggling with some anxieties that I've
never really experienced before
um not not really sure where to go with
it but I know I don't want to feel like
that anymore um I'll give you a quick
backstory on it I was married for 20
years I'm I'm a Christian man uh my
ex-wife just kind of abruptly up and
left she had her own
kind of mental health issues that she
was dealing with and some past traumas
Etc and uh so yeah there was about a
three-day notice and then poof
everything had changed and and this
anxiety that I felt was I mean I got
through it that was five years ago and
uh you know I kind of held on to hope
that you know things were going to work
out I'd be patient about it and uh you
know again my faith played a large role
in that and you know I was I was pushed
and pulled and pushed and pulled and
kick to the curb and finally I said
enough's enough I ventured out met a
wonderful girl everything was great
seeing for about four months and then I
started to feel her pull away and I I
thought I had dealt with all those
anxieties and the this the minute she
started to pull away I was hyper aware
of every single text message the tone of
her voice body language I felt like I
did the first day my wife left and uh
it's yeah it's been you know it's been a
week of of just that just that that pit
in my stomach and I I I need to I need
to not feel like that okay um anytime
somebody says that after 20 years
somebody abruptly
left I always want to push on that a
little bit okay when she when she when
your ex-wife tells you and and I'm going
back that far for a reason okay so I'm
not just just playing around um when she
told you why she
left did she paint a picture of a long
story or is it really like no I woke up
on Tuesday and decide I'm
good uh well funny answer to that is um
she never really told me
why uh it it it it took about two and a
half years for her to to kind of
pinpoint to herself uh why and and I
guess that came down to she did say she
wasn't happy for a while um there was a
lot of outside stressors outside of our
marriage not saying that I didn't have
anything to do with you know definitely
could have been more supportive more
involved that kind of thing outside
stressors like
what uh she has a daughter who has uh
been struggling with the drug addiction
and um you know we had custody of
grandkids at the time that was um our
child services up in C basically dumped
them off at the house and said if you
guys don't take them they're going to
get separated they're going to go
somewhere
else so it was uh yeah so did she take
did she take those
kids with her we did yes no no no when
she left you oh uh no uh by the time the
actual split happened uh things had kind
of worked out there and the children
were returned back to them to uh to the
mother okay here here's what I'm getting
that um I don't want you to look at
anxiety as something that you worked
through
okay it serves an important role in your
life it just has to serve the right role
okay so um we all have a friend or
hopefully you have a friend who would
like if y'all were out having a drink or
something and somebody mouthed off at
your wife this friend would be hitting
that person before you even realize what
it Happ happened right we all want a
friend that defends us and then there's
that idiot friend who defends us like
that when we don't need it or don't want
it and it causes like a big melee right
similarly anxiety works for us it just
doesn't always work in the right place
at the right time if you told me after
20 years two decades of building a life
with somebody you all took on foster
kids you took on an external I mean you
took took on somebody else's daughter
and raised them as your raised her as
your own and dealt with all the mental
health and addiction challenges all that
stuff and then one day someone just she
just
leaves that would shake the sidewalk
that would shake the the foundation of
your life like to where your feet
wouldn't ever feel
secure and so then you meet somebody
after five years and it sounds like you
and your ex are still talking o
throughout this like even though y'all
have been divorced for five years now
y'all still are in communication is that
right well there's a little bit more of
that story um I can let you finish your
your thought there go for it go ahead
and fill me in okay so um so yeah um you
know my my ex was always around she was
always kind of kept me at Arms distance
and she's been clear that you know she
has a hard time seeing a life without me
and uh I kind of had to come to the
point and say like look you know I I
can't be your friend I could be friendly
but I need to this isn't going anywhere
this isn't going to get fixed Etc what
did she accomplish by divorcing
you uh did she want to sleep with other
people did she just want to live in her
own house like what was she going
for uh I don't I don't have an answer
that she did get involved with uh
another guy you know within a couple
weeks after about three weeks after
leaving so there was somebody else and
then it was going to fix everything and
then it didn't and then all of a sudden
realized what she lost right yeah okay
so uh fast forward to so when I sent in
my submission originally um you know my
biggest concern was just feeling that
anxiety from my new partner pulling away
from me well fast forward you know a
week um that partner uh you know said
that it's not fair how she's treating me
she's distant and cold she has a lot of
stuff going on it is what it is um that
put me into this again that spiral of
anxiety uh and then just last night my
ex-wife reached is out out of the blue
saying that she's made a terrible
mistake
and so right that's that's a whole
another whole another thing but um so
here's the deal the the anxiety's
right it remembered think of it as a GPS
pin your body put a GPS pin in the
moment that the woman you were married
to after 20 years up and left
you it also put a GPS pin in you didn't
know what do you do for a
living police officer oh my gosh of god
dude lead with that man so a guy who
knows everything and shows up to the
worst sit no one calls you because
they're having a great
day and you go and you have to solve
these problems you have to know what to
do next and you now have to know what to
do next in very tense uncomfortable
situations that are being filmed and
broadcast all over the world 247
365 yeah and you missed it your own
house right yeah yeah your body puts a
GPS pin in something really scary which
is Jesse no longer trusts
Jesse huh and then you meet somebody
new and your body is like man this feels
good this is like a real human being
she's beautiful she laughs she's funny
and then it is hyper
aware to take care of you to love you
your body's doing its job when she
starts to pull away she takes a little
bit longer to respond to that text you
know I don't know if you've been through
detective Academy but one of the things
they teach you in detective Academy is
walk into a room and exhale
first and see if you can feel something
that doesn't look right doesn't feel
right your body's doing that for you 247
365 so I think the anxiety you feel is
right on I would be worried about you if
this had happened and you were like all
right cool on to the next I would be
like man you should probably go talk to
somebody fair enough the challenge for
you is twofold one don't instantly try
to make that anxiety go away which
getting back with your ex-wife tonight
because it she would be warm and she'd
be
comfortable would make that anxiety go
away
today and it you'll wake up tomorrow
dude and it will be back with a
vengeance and you know that
I do yeah so head into the anxiety feel
it let it be a part of you that sounds
that sounds terrible it is but hey it's
like dude you don't go to the gym and
take all the weight off the
bar you go to the gym and put on as
heavy as you can possibly lift why
because there strength on the other side
of
that and it sucks it's not
fun so when your body's trying to get
your attention head towards you do this
for for a living man you run to the fire
you run at the
shots and no anxiety there whatsoever no
because you've trained it a thousand
million billion times and you trust your
training and and you trust your uh you
trust your
partners but you don't trust Jesse
anymore wow
Fair yeah so here's what I want you to
do with it okay um one once you hang on
the line I'm going to send you a free
copy I'll mail it up there to Canada for
you of of my new building a non- anxious
Life Book okay I'm G send that to you
it's got a road map to it the second
thing is I want you to begin to write
down and every police officer I know
from my dad to my friends everyone I
know all the guys done Patrol with they
carry those little black notebooks I
want you to get a separate one just for
you and I want you to write down when
you start feeling anxious she hasn't
she's not responding to my text she's
not doing this she's not doing that I'm
doing this I want you to write that crap
down and get out of your
body okay later on at night later on in
the afternoon when you get done working
out it's almost always better to do
something physical before you start
reviewing stuff because your body State
changes but want you to go to the gym go
for your walk go for your exercise get
off shift whatever you need to do and I
want you just to take 30 minutes 10
minutes five minutes look at that list
you've written for the day and say is
this
true is this true okay is she really
avoiding me maybe or maybe she had dihe
when you texted man and she just I made
that weird I'm sorry but like no she had
diarrhea and she just didn't have her
phone with her thank God I don't want to
you don't want to date somebody that has
their phone with them while they have
diarrhea so like maybe that's what
happened or maybe no this is a pattern
this is a pattern and yeah we need to
have a hard
conversation yeah see what I'm saying
yeah I'm with you and here's the last
thing I want you to do I want you to be
really really really honest honest with
yourself I have been unable to be honest
with myself in this way without talking
to somebody else so yes I'm recommending
that all of my police officer friends um
see a counselor have some sort of person
I also recommend that if you can find
somebody that's not in your Precinct
that's not like yeah go talk
to man that's tough stuff because they
got to keep notes but you can go find
somebody off the off the path and
obviously if you need to get help get
help from wherever you need to get help
from right um and it's Precinct specific
as to what kind of care they provide but
want you go talk to somebody have
somebody that you can process this this
one important fact what did I contribute
in my first
marriage because part of rebuilding
trust with Jesse is owning reality being
honest with
yourself man I actually was married to
my job more than I was married to my
wife I actually got home and after being
the person that everyone in the
neighborhood called I also treated my
wife like she was one of the callers
well you need to do this you need to do
this I often fill in the blank fill in
the blank fill in the blank what world
did I create for my
wife that ultimately she was like I'm
out and dude maybe nothing but very
rarely is it nothing I'm confident you
contributed something to that
environment to that world and be honest
about the signs that you missed and
here's what we're doing we're letting
our body know I'm driving again I'm back
in the driver seat of my own life this
is building a non-anxious life but this
is dealing with anxiety don't run from
it take those ruminating thoughts write
them down get them out of your
head and then be really honest and
reflective when you start owning reality
choose reality what role did I play in
this
thing and as you head into new
relationships man knock your lights out
and by the way to answer your your last
question your kind of sidebar question I
don't have a problem with it if you
decide to get married again but go real
real slow
really really slow and don't use your
ex-wife as a
Xanax to not feel so anxious anymore she
didn't deserve that and you don't
either go
slow grateful for you brother thanks for
your service my man every day you're out
there for us grateful for
you